Speaker 1: Ladies and gentlemen, welcome inside
the new studio. I know it looks very much the
same, but it is very much different. And I know
it will probably sound a little different for
a couple of days. Dealing with an echo. You
don't need to email me about the echo we're
dealing with. It's still treating the room.
Please bear with me as we work through some
technical elements here, and I know it looks like
I have a wire coming out of my right arm, and I
do. It's been implanted to connect directly to the
studio. No, I'm kidding. Let's get right into it,
because there is so much to talk about. It is not
yet over in Arizona in a number of different ways.
And of course, it is completely over in Arizona
in terms of Kerry Lake is not going to be the
next governor from Arizona. So let's take it step
by step. In Maricopa County, they they held and by
they, I mean the county authorities and people
who believe Kerry Lake actually won. They held
a hearing. And the hearing was so insane and
so depraved and so outrageous that within just
moments it went bad. I want to look at a couple
of these moments with you again as a reminder that
these people will go for years. You know how
sometimes you look at a little puppy dog or a
toddler and they seem to have endless energy, and
you say, well, I've already thrown the ball 100
times. I've already picked up the spoon 500 times.
And it's still interesting and you still want to
do it again. And the answer is they will go for
years. They are still not over the results of
the 2020 election and now they are getting going
with 2022. Here is a woman who says she is there
somehow related to wanting a new election and
also her children were once taken away from her,
which is certainly odd. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: I am questioning why is nobody talking
about us or the media and nobody like I'm just
like mother trying to save my family because my
kids were taken from me when they were little
because I fought for them. Medical freedom.
Speaker 1: Because. So it sounds like
the children were taken away for for
reasons of neglect. And this is the person
who knows we should have a new election.
Speaker 2: I don't go there. Okay. But I
want to tell you, those guys, I feel this
like a joke. But please, Arizona. I love
Arizona. I love all of you. I love you,
Stephen. I voted for you. Okay? This is not about
hate and love and hate. You know what? Love is
to say no to wrongdoing, you know, and and please
try to understand those people how upset they are.
Speaker 1: Yeah, everybody's very upset
because their candidate lost. And yet they
want a new election because of that. If we won,
it was fair. If we lost, it was rigged. Here is
another woman who believes there were hundreds of
thousands of people in Arizona who could not vote.
Speaker 2: There's a statistician online
that's already done statistics on these guys.
Speaker 1: It's a statistician who's
done statistics. What else do you need.
Speaker 2: To disenfranchisement based on
Richard's numbers and how he calculated
people waiting in line? It's over hundreds
of thousands of people that were not able
to vote right that they disenfranchized. The
second thing is everybody that's been paying
attention for way years before 2020 and then
when 2020 came along and they've been paying
attention since then, do not trust these
machines. There have been investigations.
Speaker 1: Mike Pillow's one of those guys.
Speaker 2: For two years. The evidence is in.
They've got it all. They're going to it's going
to bubble up to the top. If we had journalists
that were doing their job and asking questions,
people would know this by now, but they don't.
So here's my next point. It's going to bubble
up. This is a fork in the road right now, today.
Speaker 1: Now, by bubble up, it sort of sounds
like she's increasingly saying that this might
lead to violence. And again, think of it,
2.4 million people voted in Arizona a few
weeks ago. She says hundreds of thousands were
disenfranchized. That sort of means like a third
of the electorate or at least ten, 15, 20%. It's
bonkers now. Then came another woman who was even
more dire and apocalyptic in her concerns.
She says if this election gets certified,
it's going to get very bad. Very quickly.
Speaker 2: Justice, you high and mighty
politicians don't even know the meaning of the
word fairness. Which of you has any left? Not one.
All your dealings are crooked. You give justice in
exchange for bribes. These men are born sinners,
lying from their earliest words. They're
poisonous, deadly snakes, cobras. They close
their ears to the most expert of charmers.
Speaker 1: So this is this is
like biblical stuff, right?
Speaker 2: Oh, God. Break off their fangs.
Tear out the teeth of these young lions. And Lord
let them disappear like water into thirsty ground,
make their weapons useless in their hands,
let them be as snails dissolve into slime.
Speaker 1: Okay. I think you basically get it.
Just crazy, apocalyptic stuff. Here is another
woman who came forward and said that the board
of electors in Maricopa County are traitors only.
Speaker 2: I came here today to
get an up close and personal look
at the seven traitors to the United States
Constitution. Again, please, at that desk.
You were set to receive a subpoena this
morning at 930. What did you do? You called
your meeting for 8 a.m.. What are you hiding?
Speaker 1: Right. We all know nothing good happens
at eight in the morning if you hold an 8 a.m.
meeting. It must be for some kind of subterfuge.
And then lastly, here is a guy again with just
more like apocalyptic Bible type stuff, and then
he throws in some Klaus Schwab World Economic
Forum conspiracy theories. Imagine getting out
of bed for this. Some people traveled from other
states, which, by the way, what stake do they
have in Arizona? That's a whole other question.
Speaker 3: The wicked flee when no one is chasing
them, but the godly are bold and lie. And if
you see any bold people who are lions here.
Speaker 1: I see bald people.
Speaker 4: They're committed
to this thing. So am I. When there is.
Speaker 2: Moral rot within a nation,
its government topples easily.
Speaker 3: But with honest and sensible leaders,
there is stability. I want you to feel shit.
Speaker 1: So there is this guy and they are
going to achieve nothing. They continue to
be convinced that they are right that they
actually won despite there being no evidence
whatsoever. Kari Lake is playing along with
these people. Kari Lake continues to say, Oh,
it's not over, it's this that. The other thing,
it is over. And there is one Arizona County who
refuses to accept it. Let's talk about that next.